officer he started a bombardment against
an italian town during the second world
war
and then he described very clearly what
it was like when the guns started to
fire back
well these are the final guns to be
fired to mark his life
and there will be what is called death
gun salutes
at seven stations across the united
kingdom each firing 41 guns over 40
minutes
and we will see it also out at sea
and in gibraltar but we see now at
edinburgh
the guns are ready from 105 regiment
royal regiment of artillery
and they will be firing on instruction
at the precise time of 12 o'clock
and this will be echoed again around the
united kingdom at precisely the same
time
each gun carefully timed to be in
accordance with all the others
and at the conclusion of it a salute
which goes back in history really to the
beginning of military time in terms of
ordinance
there will be a continuation of that
tradition
for 41 well the tradition goes that
each of the major ships at sea had
20 guns on each side of the ship and
one signal gun and the signal gun was
fired to start it
and then they cleared the guns on each
side of the ship making a total of 41.
and it's very rare to have a death gun
salute
but this privilege has been accorded to
the duke of edinburgh
by her majesty the queen
alistair stay with us i'm just going to
bring in our royal correspondent
rhiannon mills
who is here and as we await those gun
salutes part of the formal recognition
of the death
of the duke of edinburgh we are also
awaiting further details about the
funeral arrangements rhiannon
we are and i i would anticipate that we
should be able to bring you some more
details
by the end of today as to how the royal
family intend to
formally mark the death of the duke of
edinburgh
of course we are living in still very
complex times at the moment when it
comes to
the coronavirus pandemic restrictions
and everything that i was hearing from
the palace yesterday and certainly this
is
the royal family's wishes as well is
that they they stick to
within those guidelines so actually yes
today at windsor we're seeing a huge
number of people
um more people than i expected gathering
here wanting to pay their respects
wanting to bring flowers
but certainly the palace have said they
don't want people to gather in crowds
they don't necessarily want people to
come to royal residences
and instead of leaving flowers they
actually want people to make
contributions
um online instead but i think as we wait
for the gun salutes to to commence
i think it's also been very important
for the royal family in some ways to
mark those traditional elements that we
would have
um with any significant royal death and
a moment of mourning like this so for
example
a notice yesterday was placed on the
gates at buckingham palace and
on the gates of the palace of holyrood
house but again quickly taken down so
that crowds
and didn't gather gather to see that and
those books of condolence normally would
be physical books
now uh moved online to again to prevent
uh people from gathering but how much of
the funeral has already been set out
in advance of this you won't be
surprised to hear that actually these
funeral plans have been
years in the making but as a result
of covert 19 they've had to be reviewed
in great detail now we know we've heard
over the years
[Music]
[Music]
uh rihanna mills uh still with me at
rhiannon
we were talking about the funeral and
the plans that are
evolving and changing as a result of the
pandemic
yes i think the queen obviously would
want to
to mark the death of of her husband
in in in a significant way
um but because of covet 19
it means that the plans have had to be
reduced significantly um i know that her
majesty was looking at plans yesterday
and and that's why we have to wait
um for that official sign off um but
certainly we will not
see that the pomp and the ceremony that
we would we would usually expect
um for a moment like this but again more
details
are due to be released later on today in
many ways does that
lower key ceremony that we might
anticipate
fit a man of the duke of edinburgh's
character
i think so and and yes it was incredibly
sad news yesterday when we heard that he
that he passed away um but i think
passing away here at windsor castle is
how he would have wanted it
a man who who didn't like a fuss who
didn't like the attention
um and yet today still we have the
crowds here wanting to mark
um his remarkable life and pay their
respects
yeah increasing numbers of people
gathering here at windsor castle rihanna
mills thank you very much
indeed uh we are anticipating that
41 gun salute in the next few minutes
let's bring in our royal commentator
alastair bruce aleister
well it's significant that the first
location we see
is edinburgh castle looking across
prince philip's dukedom
of edinburgh a title that he was given
on the morning of his marriage to
princess elizabeth by king george vi
and the castle from which this salute
will be fired of 41 guns
appeared in his coat of arms and in the
badge that he always used on all his
stationary
and he held that name of the castle of
edinburgh and the dukedom of edinburgh
throughout his service to the queen
and he visited on many occasions he was
the
chancellor of the university here and
we have now from 105 regiment the guns
are
manned with the soldiers of this
volunteer regiment
regimental reserve that
have been training not only first thing
this morning but also yesterday
and the guns will start in 30 seconds to
fire
this death gun salute in marking a life
of service to the queen by her consort
and these will be echoed at six other
locations
and also on board two ships at sea
and in gibraltar
uh
it has just gone noon you're watching
sky news live coverage of the death gun
salute
to mark the duke of edinburgh who died
yesterday
and returning to edinburgh castle where
there is now
time for the gun which has just fired to
be reloaded
and also time to reflect again on how
the duke of edinburgh had carried the
name of this city
the capital of scotland in his life
all around the world and for him
therefore this firing of the gun
has its own significance as the next gun
is fired
we now go across the country to london
where the simultaneous second shot has
been fired by the honorable artillery
company
the oldest regiment in the british army
the tower of london
where the crown jewels of the united
kingdom are stored
and to which the duke came on a number
of occasions not least
when he was appointed by the queen to be
the chairman
of the coronation committee just after
she came to the throne and organized
the coronation in 1953. it is the great
citadel
of england and it is the well-known
guarding point at the entrance of london
where the prince
did so much of his service to the queen
working from palace
and at cardiff castle too preparing for
this gun salute
you'll see the firing and then the
discharge
of the shell case they are of course
blank firing
today but these guns new battle and
they were guns that were in operation
and service in
some of the battlefields that were being
fought hard over
when the duke of edinburgh as a young
officer in the royal navy
was along with the army and the royal
air force across all the allies
fighting against the axis powers of
tyranny in the second world war add to
fire
of the queen when she is in northern
ireland of course throughout the queen's
reign
the struggles for
security and peace within a nation that
has a history of discord
has been very much a part of the queen's
reign and we remember when
the duke of edinburgh accompanied the
queen to go to
ireland on that historic state visit
and also what a great deal it had meant
to him
to see peace returned there after the
struggles
of that time particularly with the loss
of his uncle
lord mountbatten but to devenport and
the royal navy
are firing their guns also
in salute at davenport the historic and
largest
of the naval bases of europe
number one gun
wearing the anti-flash that is always
worn on board ship particularly when
guns firing in battle
battles that prince philip as i say
remembered very much
seeing start in italy at the beginning
of his service in the second world war
and suddenly realizing as he said and
then they all started firing back and
you suddenly realized
that this was real war he was also out
in japan
at the time that the peace was finally
assigned
at the end of hostilities in 1945.
we now get willage with its ancient
history
as a scene of the revittling of ships
nearby at detford
and royal horse artillery
are preparing to fire their guns the
king's troop royal horse artillery
[Music]
the guns here are firing in front of the
largest frontage of
any building of the georgian period one
thousand
feet long massive building with the guns
laid out
in front of the center of that building
where the old officer's mess and
the duke of edinburgh frequently went as
a guest there
because his reach into the armed forces
was so considerable
as a field marshal for longer than
anyone else had ever been
in
going to portsmouth next and at
portsmouth where so many occasions
a young naval officer prince philip
would have set out to see
to play his part in the battles and
again the anti-flash will remind us
of what warfare's like in a ship
and perhaps one of the most dangerously
protected areas
during the second world war was in
gibraltar where the great guns
were protecting the entrance to the
mediterranean and through which
their submarine nets prince
saw that preparation as the guns fired
there too
enormous amount of smoke and the
well gibraltar regiment will after all
had to defend the rock through some very
difficult times in history
going way back to the very start of its
part of british ownership
back to edinburgh castle and the seat of
the dukedom of edinburgh
and the gun is about to be fired
and it's a beautiful day in edinburgh
too with
the wonderful views from the castle i'm
very proud to be
its governor at the moment and i'm very
proud too
of the excellence of the royal regiment
of artillery in delivering
this salute to the duke of edinburgh and
what a day
and the duke who loved scotland he was
educated at gordenstein
he was up at balmoral with the royal
family frequently and each year
the queen and he came up for royal week
to mark the duties and particularly
opening the scottish parliament
when that moment came
so looking back around the country all
the
various places not least gibraltar as
they prepare to fire again
the duke of edinburgh was made colonel
of the welsh guards quite soon after the
queen came to the throne
and so with the welsh guards that
service continued
and his connections with the
principality carried on until his son
the prince of wales took on that title
and
the duke stepped away for the grenadier
guards but
again a sense of the reach of the
duke of edinburgh into so many parts of
british life
united kingdom life and also out around
the commonwealth
and these gun salutes have been fired in
others of the queen's realms
and earlier on today in australia too
outside the parliament building in
canberra but back to
hillsborough castle in northern ireland
again the soldiers firing here are
reservists from 105 regiment royal
artillery
and they are the same regiment as our
firing in edinburgh castle
all reservists all who have trained and
prepared over the last two days but
always been on tenterhooks
for the responsibility of delivering
this salute on behalf of her majesty the
queen to her husband
he was just two months short
of his 100th year being complete
and today the 10th of april his birthday
would have been the 10th of june
so as we move on round
the united kingdom to plymouth
and an echo again of the many times that
the young naval officer or
as a senior admiral he came in and out
of this
great davenport dockyard
not too much fuss that duke of edinburgh
often used to say
about any arrangements for his funeral
and one can only understand that despite
this constant desire to
stick a pin into the pomposity of
british life he recognized that as the
queen's husband
this is a part of the queen's life and
it is the way the united kingdom mocks
its passing through time back with the
king's troop
royal horse artillery who were given
that name by prince philip's
father-in-law
king george vi when he visited the
months they were called the riding troop
he crossed out the word riding and put
kings
when the queen came to the throne she
insisted
that the name of her father be marked
going forward
and you heard the officer commanding
there who is also known as the
commanding officer
of the king's troop and major victoria
flood
said it is a privilege for all those
from the king's troop
to be commemorating the passing of his
royal highness to duke of edinburgh it
is a responsibility
we do not hold lightly and one that is
an honor they brought the horses
out to bring the guns here to the front
of willage
earlier today
and rhiannon as we go back to gibraltar
it is perhaps interesting to reflect
upon as these guns go on firing with the
excellence
of the armed forces strict adherence to
discipline and timing
that we'll hear the first gun
just before
before gibraltar
and i was going to say to you rihanna
that they
mark each gun as it's fired in a little
tiny leather wallet
and they stick a little pin through the
card in the center to make sure
that they fire precisely 41 guns but
what a day rhiannon
i think for the royal family and
for people across this nation and across
the commonwealth
it has been this is an important moment
for them to
mark the death of the duke of edinburgh
in those significant
traditional ways yesterday we saw
a notice being posted on the gates of
buckingham palace
on the gates of the palace of hollywood
house
marking what is a significant moment for
this nation
as we say goodbye to britain's longest
serving consort of course we have to
remember that this is
a family here in mourning now we
pay our respects to her majesty the
queen now
a widow remembering those moments that
she shared
with her husband but also here at
windsor castle the crowds wanting to
come out and pay their own respects
to a man who has left the most
remarkable personal legacy
both for this country and also for
countries
across the commonwealth his death has
given us an opportunity
to look back on hundreds of
hours of video footage and thousands of
photographs which really helped to
highlight that enduring working
partnership
but also that love match that developed
between the queen
and the duke during 73 years of marriage
and these moments yes are important to
mark the traditional
moments to to have the gun salutes
to have the flags at half-mast but this
is a family who
behind palace walls will also be marking
the death
and mourning the loss of a man who meant
so much to all of them
and rhiannon as the gun salutes were
getting underway
across the uk we saw the earl and
countess of wessex
driving past our live position here past
the crowds
gathering outside windsor castle
the countess of wessex had her window
down tears in her eyes and she spoke
to you as she passed what did she say
she did
and she said to me i asked
how are you all and she simply said the
queen
has been amazing with tears in her eyes
and i think it was it was quite a moment
to see
her husband prince edward in the driving
seat the countess
sophie sitting alongside him um driving
slowly passed our life position here
but also stopping to
have a few words with some of the crowds
who gathered and she was saying thank
you
to people who'd come here wasn't she she
was and and i think it's it's a
difficult balancing act for the royal
family at the moment
yesterday we were told that they wanted
to take some private time
um to mark the death of the duke of
edinburgh which is completely
understandable
but also there is this awareness that we
are still living
in these times of the coronavirus
pandemic
and the restrictions that are in place
and
they do not want to be seen to be
encouraging crowds to gather but
really spontaneously today we can see
there are there are so many people here
hundreds of people gathering
and wanting to bring flowers wanting to
pay their respects and wanting to mark
what is a significant moment in our in
our nation's history
and so i think for for the ireland
council of wessex
they wanted to slowly take that time to
to drive past the crowds
and in a socially distanced way be able
to
to say their thanks because they will of
course have been aware of
of the the thousands of tributes coming
from
across the country from around the world
people having their
own recollections and memories
of meeting the duke of edinburgh and i
think that moment
seeing the countess of wessex there very
much summed up that
uh public grief and that private
mourning as well rhiannon thank you very
much
indeed for now let's return now
to the 41 gun salute the tower of london
now alistair
well it reminds me very much of the fact
that
prince philip had two appointments that
he really treasured that his forebear
prince albert the prince consort also
held one was
chancellor of cambridge university but
the other very close to the tower of
london
is trinity house that look after all the
lighthouses up and down the nation and
for a book that i was
putting together with a photographer
called julian
calder we took his photograph as the
master
of trinity house on deptford strond
and he came into the photograph saying
come on you've only got a few seconds
and he was in a bit of a sort of hurry
and he was never easy having
his photograph taken he absolutely hated
it
and as we wait just for the gun to fire
julian the photographer said from
underneath his
cover any chance of a smile nothing
try it again any chance for a smile
nothing
and then i said julian you'll get what
you're given
and then he did smile and that was the
photograph we used
and in a way his dislike of
photographers and perhaps of the media
in general
was because it always took up quite a
lot of his time and
i think he was always trying to get on
with the next challenge now the armed
forces who we see here
playing their part and with whom the
duke of edinburgh spent a great
deal of his time may have these
traditions
but their real purpose is the defense of
the queen's realm
so as we hear the next gun fire
into water where the weather is somewhat
different
the gun will fire shortly
as i was saying we're watching and
witnessing the great traditions of the
armed forces
but also prince philip was committed to
the modernization
the endless desire to be constantly at
the forefront of battle
because he knew how important that was
himself as a young officer
fighting his ship in the great struggle
against tyranny
in the second world war and it is that
pursuit
of technological advance that he was so
fascinated
about back in portsmouth where so much
of that technological
naval advance takes place they fire
again
and the ferry service going in and out
of the narrows
from portsmouth harbor one of the most
fascinating
routes in and out through spit head and
past the towers that were built
to protect the united kingdom
from napoleon in those troubled times
and
through which prince philip would have
navigated his ships
as a young officer and later on board
the royal yacht as it went out
with the queen two tasks and at willage
again
uh we'll see the next gun fired by the
king's troop royal horse artillery
and these guns were also fired at the
wedding
of the princess and the duke
in 1947 when they were married in
westminster abbey
and of course they fired again for the
announcement of the king's death in 1952
and for the coronation in 1953
a total change around for prince
philip's life he left the navy in order
to support the queen
he had been a destroyer captain
in the mediterranean fleet and so
it was a great change back up to
edinburgh castle
and the castle that takes its position
in the city from which
he took his title's name he was also
earl of marianas
in wales and baron greenwich in england
the duke of edward was also appointed a
knight
brethren of the most ancient and most
noble order the thistle in scotland
which is the oldest and most senior
honor there
and he held many appointments within the
regiments
of scotland not least more recently in
the royal regiment of scotland that was
formed out of so many
of those great military traditions and
edinburgh castle
is the very seat and stronghold of the
scottish
marshall tradition and back across the
irish sea to hillsborough
and with what joy the good friday
agreement brought
to this province during
an important part of the queen's reign
and rhiannon you have watched the
preparations and you believe that we
will hear more detail
from buckingham palace who are
responsible for releasing details
later on and sarah will take us through
that
indeed alastair thanks very much uh in
the last moment or two we've seen the
duke of york
driving out of the gates of windsor
castle
past us here and uh towards the town
center rihanna mills our royal
correspondent with me at the island
countess of wessex and the duke of york
now having
left been inside the castle with their
mother
the queen and presumably those funeral
arrangements will have been under
discussion with the family well we know
that yesterday
the prince of wales spent time with her
majesty the queen he traveled from high
grove
to come and spend time with his mother
and yes as you say we've just seen
prince andrew driving himself away from
the castle
earlier on we saw prince edward and the
council of wessex
and yes i suspect an important time for
the family to
privately mourn together but also
discuss
the next steps and and the funeral plans
before
they're put out there into the public
domain which i anticipate we will have
more details by the end of today but as
we were talking about earlier
the funeral plans have been a very long
time in the planning
however because of coronavirus they've
had to be
reviewed looked at again um and i think
for her majesty the queen yesterday she
was looking at those funeral
arrangements
and and maybe today wanted to sit down
with the family and
discuss what will happen in in the days
ahead
also important for the family uh to
gather
to support their mother the queen
the queen and duke of edinburgh have
been isolating here at windsor castle
for the past
year nicknamed hms bubble uh
they've spent perhaps more time together
in the last year rhiannon than
for a very long time in their lives it's
interesting to reflect on that and and
in some ways potentially
it will make the duke's death harder for
the queen because they have spent
a great deal of time together in the
last year um
it was decided that this was the best
place for them to be um during the
pandemic
and before that actually they spent
quite a lot of time separately since the
duke had decided to
to step away from from public life in
2017
and the duke enjoying his retirement um
not exactly putting his feet up but
certainly taking some time away from the
cameras away from the spotlight
and spending time in norfolk and the
queen of course having to stay
at buckingham palace and at windsor
carrying out those important duties
as head of state but while we've talked
a great deal i think over the last what
24 hours since it was announced that
prince philip had had passed away
um we've talked a lot about them being
an important working partnership the
queen and the duke supporting each other
um the important role that he held as as
her a dedicated consort
but also a devoted husband and wife
parents and grandparents and certainly
prince philip was
always recognized as a very important
sounding board behind the scenes
for members of the family no not overly
sentimental but certainly
sympathetic at times and always there to
give advice
and um yeah i have to say it was it was
very moving
to see um the earl and the council of
wessex driving
very slowly past the crowds here um
sophie had
tears in her eyes and and simply said to
me
the queen has been amazing um and
yeah it's difficult to think isn't it we
have a monarch here at windsor castle
um who is now mourning the death of of
her her life partner yes very much a
couple of that generation
and i suspect very very stoic about
about death and
and they have both lived a long and
happy life but no doubt
as she described there is there is deep
sorrow at saying goodbye
um to her beloved husband as we see his
death being marked
um in these traditional ways they had of
course been separated for a prolonged
period during the duke's stay
in hospital added poignancy that he was
able
in fact to return here to windsor castle
for his final days
and i i think that's the way that he he
would have wanted it this was a man who
who didn't like a fuss we know didn't
have much time for that for the cameras
and
and the intrusion that they felt on
their private lives
and and i think when when he left
hospital you could see that there was
there were great efforts um there were
great efforts to try and protect his
privacy as he was leaving hospital
and when we saw the photographs um of
him in the back of the car i
i couldn't help but think actually this
is not the way that prince philip would
want us all to see him and that is why
he stepped away from from public life in
2017
he didn't want to grow old in public and
speaking to those who who close to him i
think there was also yes
there's sadness for us that we won't
mark his 100th birthday
but actually for him i think this is
this is the way that he he would have
wanted to go he was at home
he was here with his with his wife and
um
and yeah that i think is yeah the
peaceful end he would have wanted
and as you say a very proud man he never
wanted to be seen walking with a stick
we we always saw him even at 99 standing
on his own
at two feet rhiannon we do now have
footage of that moment as the earl
encounters of wessex
uh left windsor castle
had been inside the castle for over an
hour
visiting the queen and just after 12
o'clock
here they are driving away
from windsor castle
acknowledging the crowds the countess of
wessex with her window down
and speaking to you i've um
i've i've interviewed the ireland
council of wessex on
a number of occasions and um it's worth
pointing out that they do live
very nearby here they live um in surrey
and they are incredibly close to the
queen
they were incredibly close um to the
duke of edinburgh they would often spend
a lot of time here at windsor um and i
actually spoke to prince edward
when the duke was in hospital and we had
we had a wonderful conversation
um about the fact that um i said
how was the how's the duke been and and
he took
prince philip he talked about how prince
philip was almost climbing the walls
he was very frustrated to be in hospital
fed up of watching the clock go round
and actually less patient
exactly wanted to get out and and at the
time
i got the sense from prince edward that
yes they had been concerned about him
um but actually he was
and there's a lorry going past this so
hopefully you can still hear me i may
pause for a moment
yeah um some generators i believe in
lighting
arriving here at windsor castle there is
a lot of activity
uh here i i presume rhiannon in the
run-up
to the funeral yes because this will be
once we find out when exactly it's
planned for um this will be an enormous
international media event and so yeah as
you would anticipate
um lots of activity already ready
building up for that
um but just going back prince edward um
you got that sense yes his father was 99
years old but had not lost that sense of
humor
had not lost that sense of um being a
little bit brusque at times and
telling people exactly how he wanted to
do things um
and and so this will come this will come
as an enormous loss and i know that they
had
spent as much time as they could with
the queen and prince philip
within the restrictions um during these
pandemic
times but you could tell from
from the countess there tears in her
eyes
but also as we were saying the royal
family do not have to leave windsor
castle
via this route this is actually the most
public route really that they can choose
when it comes to driving away from the
castle
so i think in some ways an
acknowledgement that yes they don't want
crowds to gather
um yes it's very difficult for them to
stop and speak because of social
distancing
um but just a chance for them to
acknowledge that people are here to to
pay their respects
um to their remarkable father rhiannon
uh thank you well that is gun salutes
continuing to take place in all four
corners
of the united kingdom dan whitehead
is at hillsborough castle for us dan
apologies we can't get to dan whitehead
at the moment let's bring in
aleister bruce our royal events and
ceremony
ceremonial uh commentator and
uh aleister just over half an hour
into these gun salutes 41
shots to be fired every minute
indeed and we're moving through the
number very gradually and
it's important to remember how much
training goes into preparing
for these gun salutes they are the way
in which the nation
announces an event in the crown's
story and preparation is hard
done and by soldiers who prepare for
their military work
first but for their ceremonial work
second and the gun
about to fire for the next minute will
be
again one of those that has been in
battle and playing its part and
you know we see in the death of the duke
of edinburgh
another death in the large list of those
who served in the second world war
and the guns which make their
saluting sign now and when in battle can
be so
incredibly overwhelming for those who
find themselves
in in the discord
and drama of battle been many many times
in which the armed forces have been
deployed on operations
not least in the protection of peace and
the complication that that is in
northern ireland
but also in other places around the
world where the necessity
was seen but back at the tower of london
where the
yeoman warders in their scarlet tudor
closed look on
in that great white tower built by
william the conqueror
and where the great principal house and
castle of safety as queen elizabeth the
first called it
a salute to elizabeth ii's husband
number two sarah you're still at windsor
alistair yes i am still here at windsor
and the crowds are continuing to swell
here outside windsor castle people are
no longer allowed to leave flowers
immediately outside the castle they're
asked to take them to the cambridge gate
at the start of the long walk but people
coming here to stop in
in quiet remembrance of the duke of
edinburgh to pay their respects and
their tributes
to a man who lived a long
and remarkable life
lots of families lots of children here
bringing their flowers
to many of us of course have only ever
known a world in which
the duke of edinburgh has been there at
the side of
his wife the queen
41 gun salutes continuing
across the united kingdom in gibraltar
and from royal navy warships
as well i believe we can bring in uh
now bishop richard moth the bishop of
arendelle and brighton joining me now
bishop mueller thank you very much
indeed for being with us firstly your
reflections
on the life and death of the duke of
edinburgh
well i think first of all i would want
to express
sincere thoughts and prayers for her
majesty the queen and the whole royal
family at this time
prince philip has been a constant
presence for the family for so many many
years
and such a tremendous support to her
majesty for so long
and it's um we can only imagine the
great loss that the family feel at this
time
it's interesting been watching these gun
salutes today
and one reflects on the
great tally of medals that prince philip
wore on his uniform and of course so
many of those came back to his own years
of active service
during the second world war and the
tremendous support and
encouragement that he gave to our armed
forces over so many years
and i know that the armed forces
community in particular will be
also missing him greatly at this time
yes and that involvement with the armed
forces not just his active
service but those long connections those
honorary appointments
that he took on for so many years
what did he mean to
the armed forces and did they mean to
him
well it was before my present
appointment i was bishop of the armed
forces for six years which was a
tremendous privilege and an honor for
for me to hold that position
um and uh i'm conscious of his very
particular links with obviously the
royal navy and the royal marines
um and the the grenadier guards and the
rifles
of course he gave up that honorary
colonel see only really very recently
um and uh it's now gone to
the the duchess of cornwall
and uh there was a huge affection for
him
um i think amongst the the armed forces
especially those um regiments with which
he had particular links with the army
uh and very particularly with the royal
navy of course since he
had served uh with the royal navy during
the second world war
so i think there was huge huge affection
for him and
and he was he showed great affection too
for all our armed forces well navy
army royal air force a constant support
for them and an encouragement to them
um and always had a good word for them
regardless of rank or station a real
interest in people and
i think there will be many uh in our
armed forces community
who will have great memories of meeting
with him over the years
um for myself
uh i have a rather wonderful
recollection of
meeting with prince philip
uh i i i was with him on one occasion at
at a luncheon
um uh sitting next to him uh most
entertaining conversation
um he was a straight talker um it could
be very very amusing
uh a real interest in a whole range of
subjects and we had
it was a wonderful occasion um
it was about ten days later i met him
again
um excuse me
and um he as he saw me he greeted me by
name
um and said how nice it was to see me
again and that stayed with me because
i thought to myself well how many people
has
that you've seen since our last meeting
it must be thousands
and yet he had remembered a name um
and so that's that's meant a great deal
to me over the years and will stay with
me always i think
um a wonderful encounter with the moment
that you just
that moment that you describe uh bishop
moth
uh fits in with what we've heard from so
many about the
duke of edinburgh really engaging with
those that he was speaking to
really listening hearing and recalling
at the details of those conversations i
wonder if you can
stay with us we'll go to cost now to uh
royal commentator alastair bruce for the
final
moments of the gun salute alastair
and this gun salute the death gun salute
for the duke of edinburgh coming to its
close here
at edinburgh castle a life that began
in the discomfort of a coup d'etat
in greece a life that involved warfare
and service as the guns are cleared on
this rampart of edinburgh castle
overlooking his dukedom
of edinburgh a life of service to the
queen
while her role as sovereign was to be
the figurehead of her armed forces
to protect the nation its freedoms and
liberties
a salute done to the duke of edinburgh
who just short
of his 100th birthday
has died and who will be remembered
for the service he gave and for the name
he carried
through his time with her majesty the
queen
as the duke of edinburgh
[Applause]
[Music]
with the guns clear they will form up at
the side of the guns and
will be brought into order by the
battery sergeant major
and the officer commanding
who will then report to the deputy
governor my representative today
colonel hugo clark and the duty done by
105 regiment royal artillery meanwhile
at the other saluting bases throughout
the united kingdom and over in gibraltar
not least the senior service of the
royal navy
they all take their leave at the
conclusion of this most ancient
most noble and most traditional
of salutes to a royal prince
alastair thank you very much indeed
let's bring in brianna mills who's with
me here
at windsor castle rhiannon alastair used
the phrase duty
done there and i suppose that is
perfectly fitting for
the life of the duke of edinburgh it is
i think at
99 years old there is this this sense
what 24 hours since we learned of his
death that
he had given his all to this institution
whether it was
as a dedicated consort to her majesty
the queen
whether it was forging his own his own
role
and trying to establish his own
place when it came to his charity work
and
supporting nearly 800 different
patronages
um but also i think supporting the
family
as well and yes we talk about the queen
and the duke being this amazing working
partnership
but they were a husband and wife they
were parents they were grandparents
and behind the scenes yes of course
publicly duty always came
first but behind the scenes he was
always a really important sounding board
um and and while we no doubt reflect on
the impact it's going to have
on on the queen it's also important to
take time to to remember
that the family also will be in mourning
and so
we know that prince charles visited her
majesty the queen yesterday but in the
last couple of hours we have also
as we've been standing here outside of
windsor castle we have seen
um prince andrew drive away in his own
car driving past the crowds
um and also significantly um prince
edward
and his wife the countess of wessex um
so i think very slowly past the crowds
um a chance for them to to thank people
who
have very spontaneously come out despite
the fact that we're still living within
these these cover restrictions but
people have
and despite the palace advice people
have still wanted to come out and
i suppose mark this moment and leave
flowers um
but the fact that the ireland council of
wessex took the time to drive very
slowly past us
and with the window down the crowds here
yeah i think
taking that time to to stop and thank
people
um they of course will have been aware
of that this outpouring of
of thanks and acknowledgement for for
what the duke has meant for
the country and and um countries right
across
the commonwealth um but i have to say it
was particularly moving
um to see sophie with with tears in her
eyes
um and she i said are you okay and
and as the car was driving past she just
turned around and said
um the queen has been amazing and and
seemed quite choked up
um by that and i think we're so used to
seeing the queen
so composed um publicly
always very together and um and so yeah
today as we we reflect on the fact that
she is now now a widow after 73 years of
marriage
um it really hit home i think um seeing
her family and
and the the upset and the sadness that
they are no doubt
no doubt going through today yeah a
family
in mourning as well as a nation rhiannon
for now
thank you very much enjoy indeed i'm
joined now by bob morris from the
constitutional unit
at university college london where he
specializes
in ecclesiastical and royal issues
bob thank you very much indeed for being
your response to the death of the duke
of edinburgh
[Music]
well it's a remarkable i wonder if you
can hear me sir yes
yes certainly yes i can say it's a
remarkable life
and which is touches all in one way or
another
and must be a source of great distress
to the queen whose support he has been
for so long
over 70 years
his actual constitutional position
strictly was much less important than
his uh informal roles that he developed
so intelligently
with such determination over a long
period he would have been the regent
had the queen been
indisposed for the time being from
undertaking her royal duties
uh during the minority of the prince of
wales
and he would have then been of course
his legal guardian
he was also one of the leading
councillors of state
when the queen was temporarily absent
for some reason or another
but since he so often accompanied her
particularly abroad he he was rarely
active as a councillor of state in that
sense
but much more important than the strict
constitutional functions
were the roles that he developed for
himself
and which did so much to support uh
aspects of
civil society and enrich our experiences
through
his endeavors
and i wonder in in shaping that role
obviously he he looked to
prince albert but this was not a man who
who wanted to share a desk with the
queen he didn't
influence her on issues of
of state he very much wanted to find his
own place
and his own role and what is your
assessment of
the role that he played well he
he was remarkable as you say he was not
an executive
uh consult in the sense that prince
albert had been
and here the the queen obviously agreed
to inhabit
very separate parts of life to our
benefit may i say
because uh the duke who remained
remarkably always his own man
sometimes in ways which shocked people
slightly he was
uh could be very forthright and perhaps
not to
caring too much about the impact of some
of the things that he said
but was always true to himself and
always carved out this remarkable
personal role
um in in his lifetime when um
it would have been difficult for people
with less energy and ability to do so
you you mentioned there his his energy i
mean this was not a man who
wanted to stand still for any period of
time was it
and and and threw himself into
all of those causes that he supported
for many many years right up until his
retirement in 2017.
yes he was certainly not just a
decorative consort
i mean there were all the roles with the
armed services of course which
no doubt he enjoyed which weren't very
valued by them
but also he probed aspects of life in
britain our business performance
and other features of that kind his
support for example for
engineering technologies and his drive
generally for modernizing the monarchy
in the face of initials some some
difficulties i think in some opposition
perhaps in
in the official royal circles
i wonder as well about that supporting
role he played
to the queen a role of support act that
he was very happy
uh to play not seeking the limelight
but how significant that was for the
queen to have him
at her side well i think
he played is the central role
of being her only equal as it were i
mean not
in terms of his official roles and so on
but the way in which she could speak
they could speak together with utter
candor
and there where she could rely on his
council as being disinterested
and always supportive and that
is a role really a function beyond price
for somebody in the queen's position
bob morris thank you very much indeed
well
let's take you now to hillsborough
castle
and dan whitehead is there and dan
hillsborough castle one of the backdrops
for the
41 gun salutes that have been taking
place across the uk and beyond
yes that's right the 105th regiment
royal artillery
were carrying out those gun salutes in
various locations around the world
including here at hillsborough castle
the royal residence
of the royal family when they come to
visit northern ireland
of course the officials here have been
urging people not to attend not to come
and leave flowers that hasn't stopped
a small number around 100 or so
during the gun salute had gathered here
we can come and take a quick look at
some of the flowers which have been
laid a lot of them from from police from
military
who wanted to come down and pay their
respects to
the duke of edinburgh who had an
affinity had a very strong connection
with
northern ireland he visited northern
ireland 56 times
during his service more than twice
actually the number of visits carried
out by the queen herself
and his first visit was in 1949
to northern ireland and his last visit
was in 2017 may 2017 when he
spoke to more than 100 young members
who'd received the duke of edinburgh
award 2017 was the year of course the
duke of edinburgh retired from public
service so
northern ireland was one of his uh last
visits
in public life which he uh carried out
um
as i say a number of people have come
down to pay their respects
gary here i was chatting to you a couple
of moments ago uh he's one of those gary
um just tell us why you um felt it
important to come and pay your respects
well coming from northern ireland and
the prince philip
obviously uh obviously wanted uh to meet
him
and i was lucky enough during the during
the duke of edinburgh award
away whenever i was 16. oh you said you
did the
award i did the award when i was 16 and
um i met him whenever we were here
and he was such a gentleman and that was
very sad yesterday to find out the news
but i also i work in education and so a
lot of my students
go through the job of edinburgh award so
i felt
privileged to have met him and do the
award with him
what were the qualities that the duke of
edinburgh had which
had such an impact on you and your
students his personality
his sincereship he was
well personally so down to earth as we
said in northern ireland
there was no errors or graces obviously
but
a lot of respect and my students just
found him
they were all anxious before
met him and they just thought gosh he
really
is such a nice